[موسيقى]
هل هي طماطم ولحم البقر الصفراء لانها
طماطم العمار
المشهورين الى حديقه جاك العامره
بالخضروات وبمثابه وضع قطط في متجر بيع
الاسماك لديهم رغبه في تذوق جميع انواع
الطماطم التي بين ايديهما طماطم خاصه
هل يمكن ان اتذوق هذا
انها مقرمشه
جيده في عالم الطبخ
الذي يستند الى الطهي التقليدي الاصيل حيث
يكون للمنتوج القيمه الاكبر في مطبخنا
رؤيتك للمسارع بشكل مباشر ومعرفتك
بالطريقه التي يعمل بها تجعلك تتفق في
المنتوج الذي ستشتغل عليها عندما يحمل
اليك الصندوق الخاصه بكافه ترجاك بكل همته
لا يسعك الا ان تحترمه وتثق اكثر في
منتوجاه
اذا كان هؤلاء الطاهات يفضلون الطماطم جاك
التقليديه
طماطم وجميع النباتات العطريه والخضر
لانني كنت دائما شغوفا بها
قصه شغف كبير بعالم الطماطم بدات قبل 40
سنه لكن لا للمبيدات الحشريه لا للبيوت
الكلاسيكيه ونعم للزراعه في الهواء الطلق
هكذا ابدا
وبكميه كبيره
رياضيه
[موسيقى]
من نوعها واصليه وحتى ترى النور لابد لها
من صبر جميل بعد بضعه اشهر تمنحنا صناديق
مزارعين المميز مهرجانات
زبائن الاديان لهم الحق في اكل النفس
الطماطم التي ياكلها زبائن باريس
[موسيقى]
بتوزيعها في باريس
يوجد واقل منها في الاسبوع المقبل هل هذا
صحيح نعم نعم مثل ما تريد
متى تكون راضيا تماما
وبطريقه تحميلها
بصوره مميزه
يجب ان تتنفس بشكل جيد
تتوجه الطماطم جاكي الى اكثر من 70 مطعم
في باريس كما تذهب الى مطابخ مجلس الشيوخ
والجمعيه الوطنيه اخره هذه الطماطم وافخم
الفنادق وارقاها مرحبا هل انت بخير
الافكار كثيره لابد لها من الوقت
سنحضر طماطم مقطعه طازجات تقدم مع محار
مدينه جغرافيه
مميزه وعمليه تجعلنا نستغني نهائيا عن
المايونيز
على كبر المواد
التي صارت شيئا فشيئا غائبه عن موائدنا
اذا كان المنتوج جيدا سواء كان طماطم او
قرنبيط او سمك الراهب اذا كان جيدا فانه
يصنع من دون شكل طبقا واصليا
اما جاكي فاذا لم نجده بين حقوره فهو هنا
من دون شك يعرض خضرواته في السوق بكل
بساطه وبهاء اعطيني واحده صفراء نعم نعم
هل ترى عندما تكون نظيفه جدا نجد بها نكهه
التفاح في هذا الركن من هذه القريه
الصغيره قد نحفر على اجود انواع الطماطم
في فرنسا لذلك قد يوجد في النهر ما لا
يوجد في البحر